the signal cup is now such a fixture on
the worldwide calendar the chest
calendar but the very first edition the
2013 Sinquefield cup was just six years
ago tell us a little bit yasser about
your memories of this birth well it's
amazing when you think about the
tournament itself happening it was a
very very real chance that wasn't going
to happen at all okay the way came about
is you know Rex wakes up one day and
he's got this inspiration I really want
to have a great tournament an elite
tournament the Piatigorsky like
tournament here in st. Louis and he goes
to joy and he says I want this great
tournament but I want Vishy Anand the
world champion to play it's got to have
the world champion okay well of course
Rex is a huge fan of Vishy Anand
absolutely
the next problem was that what time
frame because the imagination was to
have ten players or twelve players and
we needed this calendar and it was
impossible there was just no dates that
would accommodate a very long event and
soon a real mentor II the stepfather of
Hikaru really came to our rescue here
said look I have a really good
relationship with these players let me
see if I can do anything well boom the
world champion this she said can't do it
I've got my training for Magnus Carlsen
his World Championship match later that
year exactly and so we thought okay if
we lose Vichy well we're not going to
get Magnus either but suno came up with
a really great idea
he said well let let me get Levon
Aronian the number two player under in
the world under contract and that might
be really interesting yeah to bring
Magnus into the fault
so Levon said you know that he couldn't
do a 12 player turn and couldn't do this
but he could do a quadrangular of four
players six round event he said yeah
okay I'll do that
and then the business manager of Magnus
says okay he can do it and then Rex says
okay if we can get Magnus we're gonna
have this quadrangular is really really
cool and then we can finesse
dates and everything like this and it's
not Maura of course also playing as well
as gotta calm ski right so that we run
it out our field to for for that very
first year exactly that we had the two
highest rated players in the United
States
hikaru and then of course the old lion
got a cow ski returning to the fold you
see and there's going to be a double
round-robin now the next problem was rec
said okay look everybody
Tony joyed myself you guys name the baby
but it's got to have st. Louis I don't
care what you call it it's got to have
st. Louis in the title right so off he
goes so then we start thinking about and
I like the st. Louis grandmasters you
know it kind of a take-off on the US
Masters golf tournament st. Louis
grandmasters Louis International was
another idea that came across but then
here came dr. jeanne had this incredible
idea why don't we call it the sea field
cup because there was the piano Gorsky
going on at the world chess Hall of Fame
there was an exhibition right so it was
just this beautiful it was a sort of
like this handover and then we came up
with a Cinco Cup Rex came back and said
what did you guys come up with we told
him he goes don't I get a vote you go
yeah it's three two one
next on the agenda so then the
tournament's all underway and it all
gets started and it was great
seriously like our new shoots out to the
lead that's like two and a half out of
three halfway point and then he comes
he's got has met his game against LaVon
LaVon that was the turnaround game right
there yeah LaVon managed to defeat
hikaru and that's really blue the 20
minute wide open I mean in wide open as
it can get with only four players
including gata Kamsky who was not doing
particularly well on this event I mean
he was a lowest rated player he was the
lowest rated player but he was really
competitive in the game she was just
very very unlucky you recall that for
that event
hikaru comes to the game with the
reflective sunglasses okay hey where's
the previous board he gets Magnus
because Magnus had adopted the guy
Magnus was like ten zero and with just
draws poor Hikaru never beaten Magnus
including some really horrible game Oh
with these sunglasses he manages to hold
Magnus quite handily in fact he had the
better end of some of these drawers
precisely so and then it comes down to
this incredible final game where Magnus
has righted the ship he's in the lead
but he's up against
LaVon who's having had this great
comeback Danna and LaVon gets an
advantage with the black pieces and if
LaVon can win and if the carrucan win
there'll be a tie break and this and
that or if la Vaughn can draw and then
Hikaru could win there's gonna be
another kind of tie break you know and
every all of these things and then you
know
Magnus dick digs in really deep and he
turns a game around and LaVon offers
Magnus a draw it was an incredible
moment because a drawl at that point
would have clinched the title for Magnus
Carlsen
and he said heck no let's go
well Murray said I were just electrified
read I still feel that magic moment
because for grandmasters your whole
attitude when you go into a tournament
is I want to win it that's what I'm here
for I just want to win the US
Championship I want to win the World
Championship no no he came Magnus kata
this tournament was like I want to play
I want to win and I want to dominate
yeah I'm here to play and you know
looking at it it makes sense in
retrospect as Magnus of course earning
the highest rating in history that means
Olmec at the highest rating in history
by just saying hey I'll just draw this
name so that it clinches me the
tournament right
and I think that for me the most
memorable thing of the event of course
that draw was but also I just think the
precedent of st. Louis becoming a part
of history exactly what was so prominent
with this event because it was the last
classical event that Magnus Carlsen
played before he became the world
champion and so it always kind of
strikes me that it was this watermark
like before Magnus and after Magnus and
we got the very last event of the before
Magnus period indeed and to that point
that you're just mentioning what was
really historic and fun was that the fee
day had announced that Chennai the home
city of this wanteth on and on was going
to be the organizer now Magnus had to
decide whether he was going to accept
the the the contract and sign the
contract and agree to play in the
tournament
and then there's historical moment of
you know Magnus inviting the press as he
signs the contract here in st. Louis for
the World Chess Championship so when you
think about the birth of the tournament
itself and then the idea that it was
going to be this elite tournament and
it's just grown Jennifer from the early
four-player you know round double
round-robin to what it's become today
but to people who are fixtures of course
our LaVon and Nakamura true magnitude
missing you're all right though he's
been in most of them of course and he
will be back for the 2019 edition as
well indeed absolutely so that was those
are my memories of the the start of the
tournament but this berth and how
difficult it was with the calendar in
just finessing the calories a day when
you think about the calendar and how
many events there are it's really really
nice that the sync Bell cup is now a
permanent fixture on the calendar it is
and now it's like we get precedents like
the calendar has gotten more and more
crowded but when you have a tournament
with the elegance the conditions and the
posterity of the Sinquefield Cup it's
like people are working around us but in
that very first year
we have to work around everyone else
precisely